you laugh at the cardinals man
do i laugh at the card or do i roll do i
roll on the ground and flip over and
just kiss the ground and say god thank
you very much for the beginning but love
you so much for the ending sure and i
don't laugh at the car that per se but
you know uh you gotta hate you gotta
look at it and say james thought as bad
as i thought you were and you know
you knew what you were doing
that's otis anderson from one of the
super bowls he participated in with the
new york giants i remember vividly chris
i was 14 years old when otis anderson
made a big splash in 1979 over 1600
rushing yards as a rookie with the st
louis cardinals a team that
really never did all that much but they
had something special in otis anderson
but he reached that higher level when he
got to the giants and won a couple of
rings
he um i can remember my dad and how
excited he was back in 1986 that otis
anderson was traded to the new york
giants you know i just i can remember
him gushing about what a good player he
thought he was and then
of course he found his role big blue
otis anderson
tough running between the tackles just
you know physical new york giants
football he fit the mold of the football
team and really as the late 80s went on
he kind of became
you know the the lifeline and soul of
that team they played through the run
game in 89 and 90s in his tough ways and
you could see right there he could still
probably carry the football a little bit
and pile on
uh there he is otis anderson joining us
now uh played for the giants for both 21
and 25 the mvp of that game otis welcome
to the program great to see you buddy
hey good morning guys
you know last week was the 30-year
anniversary of that win in super bowl
25. to me one of the most exciting and
compelling super bowls of all time
what's the one enduring memory for you
from that game
i would say that uh
whitney he used to say in the national
anthem just just completely fooled
everyone
no one knew that she was performing and
to see her come out a native of new
jersey to come out and sing the national
anthem and the way she did it uh and
based on what was going on during that
time of the uh of the year it was uh it
was incredible it was incredible all of
us
yeah gulf war had just started not long
before that and uh that was a moment
that really galvanized the entire nation
the moment that galvanized everyone's
eyes to the tv was that field goal tried
by the bills at the end where were you
during that moment were you looking were
you head down were you
hiding somewhere where take us through
what you experienced as that kick went
up into the air
well i was toward the end of the
bench toward the uh heading toward the
locker room if if he missed that field
goal i'm not being a good sport i'm
going in i'm just done because it's such
an emotional game and but you know
overall i probably would have stayed out
there because my my ex teammate leonard
smith was playing for for buffalo at
that time but
how i knew he missed the field goal i
was looking over at ma levy
and uh andre reed
and james lofton was holding hands and
when that kick started off their hands
started going up in the air and i was
like oh shoot and then i saw their hands
drop and as i saw their hands drop i see
the ball drifting to the right and i
said he missed it and disney running
behind me saying you're the mvp of the
super bowl what
oh otis more on that game because of
course it's one of the greatest upsets
in super bowl history it was the great
you know air show of jim kelly and the
buffalo bills
how about like your mindset going into
the week like were you prepared did you
know that it was gonna just be a ground
and pound otis anderson you know work
session
going into the game
well chris you know um
ron the late ron earhart and parcells
and my coach uh ray hanlon sat down
after all the team meetings was over
with and they said listen this is our
game plan we want to run you to your
tongue fall out
so
what place
are you comfortable hey chris you know
they're coming from parcels from your
dad you know how you talk
so he said what plays do you like to run
best and i said coach if you could keep
me between the titles i really
appreciate it and then bill said well
you know we got to trick him every once
in a while we got to get you to the
perimeter that's the only way we're
going to be successful but i know we
have megan to get us around the corner
but every once in a while we got to take
you to the corner i like okay coaching
and that game all had two plays they
went outside one went to the left by the
goal line and the other one was around
the left side where i hit kelso with
that uppercut
that's the next question i want to ask
about i mean to me that is the lasting
image other than the missed field goal
is o.j anderson winding up the big right
hook like had you had you done that i
don't remember watching you in prior
games you know with the giants ever
throwing the uppercut out like that
well when i came in as a rookie from
miami i did it a lot in saint louis and
uh
and i just never had really you know a
chance to do it when i became a giant
because you know behind you know joe
mars who did everything when i got there
in 86 and then 87 was to strike and in
88 i played gold line and short yardage
so i really didn't have a chance to to
to execute it but i knew i always had if
i needed it and uh that play just just
i just wanted to really intimidate him
so bad and made him really think about
how he wanted to tackle me and so that's
what that form was all about
oh just take us back to that late 1980s
locker room for the new york giants
where there's a little blond-haired
foul-mouthed kid running around do you
have a memory
of chris sims
in the giants locker room
you know what uh
chris was always a little busybody when
you know like on saturdays you know most
guys brought their kids to to practice
and you know chris chris shows signs
that he could be an athlete you know
he'd throw the ball around run around
with us i mean it was good overall he
was pretty good kid well manor kid and
uh you know i'm just so happy to see him
follow his dad footsteps again you know
being a true quarterback and then here
he is doing a great job as a broadcaster
so uh the apple still doesn't fall too
far from the tree
yes
i was a good kid
well i'm gonna i'm gonna ask him if he's
aware of the incident during the
quarterback controversy between phil and
jeff hostetler of someone
putting shaving cream in the cleats
of jeff hostetler were you aware of that
i heard the story about it we still
don't know
[Laughter]
yeah we definitely do we do yeah i mean
you know i was a 10 year old kid sitting
in the locker room doing my homework
nobody was around and some guy was
trying to take dad's job so i had to you
know give dad a little advantage
one thing
go ahead oh that's what we're gonna say
uh i'm gonna say you know chris you know
we did a lot of practical jokes back
then doing that doing that era man we we
did that thing you remember do you
remember when uh phil your dad uh had
fish tied to the engine of his car it
drove around all week with that smell
remember that i've heard i've heard yes
somebody put it in the back like
underneath his back seat of his car he
had no idea he's coming home no diana i
don't know what the hell is wrong with
my car it smells
like jim bird or bart oats put a dead
fish back there or something
that was it yeah
oh otis i i i'm always
you're
you you you're just the epitome of like
old school smash mouth running back
when you look at the current state you
know of running backs in the nfl or just
the way the game's played like what's
the number one thing that jumps out to
you compared to your day
well you know i always try to evaluate
what players could have played during
the era that that your dad and i played
in and uh you know and uh who come to
mind is dear henry yeah he is a beast of
a running back i think he could have
played in the era that we played in and
you know the rules have changed so much
like you look at what these guys are
doing i mean for instance your dad
played i believe 14 15 years maybe your
dad could have probably played could be
still playing based on how the rules
have changed the way you hit the
quarterback because your dad was such a
workout kind of guy he worked out the
offensive lineman a lot with bart and
those guys and he was very strong so he
could have easily been still playing you
know for a lot longer than what he did
but you know the rules just changed and
made the game so much
i guess easier uh and uh and you can see
it by the way the records are falling
yeah you you feel like you probably
could have played a few
extra years of your career if you played
this day and age with you know less head
hits to the head and some of the things
that are even set up for the running
back you feel that way for that position
too well yeah i feel that um
the running back position
you you probably could because they
utilize so much different than what it
was when i played you remember you know
um chris
my era you stayed on the field every
down you didn't wasn't a third down
specialist uh if it was
second alone you didn't bring in someone
you kept your main person in the game
because he's capable of doing things for
you you know so you didn't take him out
today you know you got specialist for
almost every situation most running
backs is on the field first down and if
it's a if it's a loss he might be off
the field on sucker down so totally
different and yeah you probably could
play a lot longer and plus they don't
hit no more they don't hit
you know right but i think it's true
padded practice
during the season and after that it's
just
just touch football
right you had an incredible career the
two super bowl wins super bowl mvp 1979
rookie of the year 1989 comeback player
of the year 10
273 rushing yards that's more than earl
campbell that's more than terrell davis
that's more than larry zonka they all
have bronze busts in canton what do we
got to do to get notice anderson bronze
busting camp man i'm glad you asked that
question i'm glad you put those stats up
there because i've been asking myself
the same question you know and you know
and chris your dad probably said the
same thing about his career is what do
we need to do like why are we not there
i just i don't understand it i don't you
know
i try not to worry about it because i
don't because i can't control it but i'm
like you guys i'm very curious to
understand what are the
the methods or what what what kind of
grading system they use to uh
enshrine people you know like me who
need who wants going there so um you
know i don't know
well hey otis tell us what go ahead go
ahead mike go no you got it mike go
ahead
well this is the this is the point where
we got to pay the bills otis is here
today on behalf of novo nordisk tell us
what you have going on with them you
know as a pet as a
patient ambassador nova notice you know
this past year has been tough for
everyone especially people like me who
live with type 2 diabetes and you know
most people don't know that conditions
like diabetes and obesity you know is a
uh put you at a higher risk of
developing severe illness from cover 19.
so i just try to continue to educate
people with diabetes to to wash their
hands and keep their hand away from
their face they social distancing and
and also you know
with diabetes and obesity and the culver
20 and the clover 30 which a lot of
people start to develop that ain't good
and that's why the nfl is
nfl alumni has a form a a relationship
with nobody noticed called huddle up
let's talk obesity and you can pick it
up on obese
with the huddle up
obesity.com to get more information
about it but nobody noticed in the nfl
is just trying to
branch the gap so that everybody
understand that you still got to work
out you still got to develop some type
of balance as you go through this whole
you know cover 19 situation you got to
continue to have conversation with your
doctors you know you can't stop doing
what you used to do because of cover 19
you still got to keep that relationship
because you know diabetes because 19
they don't take a day off and they don't
go away
i mean great cause what you're doing i
mean you're right overall health i mean
especially during this time how could
that not be a positive or something you
want to do and i i'd like to end it with
that too you the workhorse oj anderson
mr right hand uppercut like
how is your body at this point right now
in your life like do you feel the wear
and tear of all those carries in the 80s
you know what they were chris i'll be
honest with you um the only problem i
really deal with is a little early
arthritis in my left hip but uh if
that's all i have after playing 14 years
and 30 years later you know and it'll
make it another effect my golf game so
i'm pretty good i'm pretty good that's
pretty good
oh you're pretty great about that i
don't know your time uh it's uh it's
been great talking to you and going down
memory lane and i i wish i could have
seen chris spraying those uh shoes full
of shaving cream all those years ago we
we know it was him and uh one of these
days we'll get jeff hostetler on here to
talk about that thanks otis great
talking to you pal all the best
yeah man you might be chris great job
man continue the great work
thanks thank you you're good otis you
the man
yeah
chris we got to get him in canton i i
don't have a vote and i never will have
one but i got to start talking to some
people who do i got to get on sheree
she's got a note we got we got to start
the otus for canton
guys well hey listen otis first and i
always worry about guys legends like
otis anderson as more time goes on they
just people forget about how great of a
player they were and it gets lost in the
shuffle and i don't think that's fair to
some of these great players
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports